Bonjour à tous, merci d'avoir
choisi de regarder cette vidéo.
Mais au fait, est-ce que vous êtes certains
d'avoir vraiment choisi de la regarder?
Vous ne croyez pas que c'est juste une série
de réactions chimiques dans votre cerveau
qui vous ont fait cliquer?
Aujourd'hui on va se demander si le libre-arbitre existe vraiment.
La plupart des gens estiment qu'ils sont doués de
libre-arbitre, c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont la capacité
de choisir et de décider librement leurs actes
Sauf que ça fait maintenant quelques dizaines d'années
qu'il y a des expériences de neurosciences
qui remettent assez sérieusement en
question cette idée de libre-arbitre.
Au point que certains en sont venus carrément
à penser que le libre-arbitre
ça n'existe pas, c'est juste une illusion.
La première de ces expériences
a eu lieu dans les années 80,
elle a été faite par un neuroscientifique
américain qui s'appelle Benjamin Libet.
Ce qu'a fait Libet, c'est qu'il a pris des sujets,
il les a tranquillement installés sur un fauteuil, confortablement,
il leur a attaché un petit capteur sur le doigt
et il leur a dit de bouger le doigt quand ils voulaient,
quand ça les chantait.
Et en même temps qu'il faisait ça, il faisait
défiler devant eux une trotteuse
qui tournait assez rapidement, un peu comme celle-ci.
Il demandait aux gens de repérer
où se trouvait la trotteuse
au moment où ils prenaient
la décision de bouger leur doigt.
Donc grâce à ce petit dispositif Libet pouvait savoir quand est-ce que les gens avaient décidé de bouger
et grâce au capteur, quand est-ce
qu'effectivement ils avaient bougé.
Ce qu'a pu constater Libet, c'est
que la décision de bouger
se produit environ 200 millisecondes (ms)
avant le mouvement.
A priori il n'y a absolument rien de choquant à ça,
la décision se produit avant de bouger, il y a
un petit temps de latence qui peut être lié au fait que
l'information voyage dans les nerfs ou peut-être
les muscles doivent se mettre en route
et ce petit temps de latence, il est de 200 ms.
Sauf qu'en même temps, Libet faisait à
ses sujets un électroencéphalogramme.
Un électroencéphalogramme consiste à
placer des électrodes sur la tête du sujet
et à mesurer l'activité électrique de leur cerveau.
Et notamment Libet mesurait un signal qu'on appelle:
le potentiel de préparation motrice.
C'est un signal électrique qui est connu
pour préparer les mouvements.
Ce qu'a constaté Libet c'est que le signal
commençait à s'élever avant le mouvement
puis retombait à peu près au moment du mouvement.
Sauf que si vous regardez bien cette courbe
vous voyez que le signal commence à s'élever
600 ms avant le mouvement.
Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure, la décision de bouger
se produit 200 ms avant le mouvement.
Ça veut dire que l'activité électrique dans
le cerveau qui prépare le mouvement
commence 400 ms avant la décision de bouger.
Cette expérience a l'air très perturbante,
elle semble nous dire que notre cerveau
commence à initier nos actions
bien avant qu'on ait décidé de les faire.
Dans ces conditions, je ne vois pas comment
je pourrais avoir un libre-arbitre,
si quand je décide de bouger le doigt en fait
mon cerveau a déjà décidé depuis 400 ms
que j'allais bouger le doigt, tout ça semble dire que
le libre-arbitre c'est effectivement juste une illusion.
Alors quand on y réfléchit un peu plus calmement,
on se dit que finalement cette expérience
n'est peut-être pas si choquante.
Ce qu'elle nous dit, c'est que dans tout processus
de décision, il y a une part inconsciente.
Ça, quelque part, ce n'est pas complètement nouveau.
On sait très bien qu'il y a tout un tas d'activités
de la vie de tous les jours où
les décisions se prennent de manière
assez largement inconsciente.
Quand vous conduisez une voiture par exemple,
ou si vous faites un match de badminton
ou que vous jouez une étude de Chopin,
tous vos mouvements ne sont pas
consciemment décidés.
L'autre raison qui fait que l'expérience de
Libet n'est pas si inquiétante que ça,
c'est qu'on est quand même en train de parler d'une
décision qui est très rudimentaire, bouger un doigt,
c'est quand même très simpliste par rapport
aux décisions qu'on peut prendre
dans la vie de tous les jours.
Je ne parle même pas des grandes décisions
comme de choisir un métier, choisir un conjoint,
ou choisir un nouveau téléphone portable.
Sauf qu'il y a quelques années, il y a des chercheurs
qui ont fait une variante de l'expérience de Libet
qui pour le coup commence à être vraiment inquiétante.
En fait dans cette variante, ils ont utilisé une IRM,
vous savez une IRM c'est ce gros appareil
qui permet de scanner votre cerveau
et utilisé d'une certaine manière qui
permet de visualiser notamment
quelles sont les zones du cerveau qui s'activent,
ça se fait en fait en observant les afflux sanguins.
Donc, dans l'expérience dont on parle
les chercheurs ont utilisé l'IRM
pour faire une variante de l'expérience de Libet,
ils ont placé les sujets dans l'IRM
comme dans l'expérience de Libet ils leur ont demandé
de bouger le doigt au moment où il le voulaient.
Sauf qu'il leur laissait la liberté de choisir s'ils voulaient
bouger la main droite ou la main gauche.
Ce qu'ils ont constaté c'est que, déjà,
il y avait une activité cérébrale en IRM
qui précédait parfois de plusieurs
secondes le mouvement,
mais qu'en plus cette activité cérébrale permettait
de prédire si c'était la main droite
ou la main gauche qui allait bouger.
Alors dans ces conditions, je ne vois pas
comment on peut dire que libre-arbitre existe.
Si avant même que j'aie décidé de bouger,
le type qui regarde l'IRM sait quand je vais bouger
et qu'il sait si je vais bouger
la main droite ou la main gauche...
Ce résultat il faut quand même le relativiser parce que
la prédiction est quand même loin d'être parfaite,
ça ne marche que dans 60% des cas.
Mais d'un autre côté, il faut savoir qu'une IRM n'est pas
non plus un appareil de mesure extrêmement précis
et on peut s'imaginer qu'on obtiendrait des
résultats bien meilleurs si on utilisait par exemple
des électrodes plantées dans le cerveau.
Je sais pas vous, mais moi ces expériences pour
l'instant ne m'empêchent pas trop de dormir.
Mais quand même, je ne peux pas m'empêcher
de penser: qu'est-ce qui se passerait si
les techniques de mesure devenaient
de plus en plus sophistiquées
et si les résultats devenaient
de plus en plus précis.
Imaginez par exemple que je vous dis:
vous venez de gagner deux semaines de vacances.
Je vais vous montrer la liste des
destinations possibles mais avant ça,
je vous met un casque sur la tête qui va regarder
ce qui se passe dans notre cerveau
Voilà, je vous montre la liste des
destinations, la voilà.
Et maintenant, imaginez qu'à peine vous ayez fini
de lire la dernière ligne, le casque vous dise:
"Ah, vous avez choisi le trekking au Népal,
excellent choix!"
Je ne sais pas vous, mais moi ça me perturberait.
On n'en est pas encore là mais qui sait
si ça ne va pas venir un jour?
Alors si ces expériences vous inquiètent,
sachez quand même qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
vraiment de consensus entre les spécialistes
sur, quelle est la bonne manière de les interpréter
et notamment les philosophes et les
neuroscientifiques ne sont pas forcément
toujours d'accord sur ce qu'il faut en conclure.
Mais c'est quand même assez intéressant de regarder
quels sont les différents camps en présence.
Il y a certaines personnes qu'on appelle
les déterministes durs.
Ceux-là, ce sont ceux qui pensent que
les lois de la nature sont déterministes,
notre cerveau obéit aux lois de la nature et donc
toutes nos actions, toutes nos décisions
sont juste la conséquence de réactions chimiques
qui se produisent dans notre cerveau
qui peuvent dépendre de nos perceptions,
de nos gènes, de notre environnement,
mais que, en définitive, il n'y a absolument
aucune notion de libre-arbitre là-dedans,
tout est déterminé et donc tout se passe comme
si on était des robots faits de chair et d'os,
mais que le libre-arbitre ne soit qu'une illusion.
Alors quand même, comme le faisait malicieusement remarquer, je crois que c'était Hawking,
même ceux qui pensent que
tout est déterminé d'avance
regardent quand même à droite et
à gauche avant de traverser la route.
La plupart des gens normaux pensent que le
libre-arbitre existe quand même.
Ok, ils reconnaissent qu'il y a des réactions
chimiques dans notre cerveau,
qu'on est influencé par nos gènes, nos
perceptions notre environnement,
mais qu'en définitive, on peut quand même
agir sur tout ça avec notre volonté.
Cette vision-là n'est pas très différente de celle que
proposait déjà Descartes il y a plusieurs siècles.
Vous savez, Descartes disait: le monde se divise en
deux catégories, c'est ce qu'on appelle le dualisme,
Il y a le monde matériel auquel appartient
le corps et qui obéit aux lois de la nature
qui éventuellement sont déterministes
et il y a le monde spirituel auquel appartient
l'esprit et l'esprit peut agir sur le corps.
Alors cette vision-là est très rassurante parce qu'elle
permet de sauver l'idée du libre-arbitre.
En même temps il faut bien reconnaître
que c'est quand même cette vision là
qui est la plus attaquée par les
expériences de Libet et consorts
et puis il faut savoir que le dualisme aujourd'hui
n'est quand même pas très populaire
parce qu'il pose plein de problèmes philosophiques.
Donc chez les gens qui sont un peu
spécialistes de la question,
il n'y a pas grand monde qui pense que
cette vision-là puisse être correcte.
Alors il existe une troisième position un peu
intermédiaire qu'on appelle le compatibilisme.
C'est les gens qui pensent que le déterminisme
et le libre-arbitre sont compatibles.
en fait ce qu'ils disent c'est que, oui
effectivement nos actions dépendent
de réactions chimiques dans notre cerveau qui
dépendent de nos gènes, de nos perceptions, etc,
mais en définitive, c'est quand même notre cerveau qui détermine nos actions,
donc voilà, on n'a qu'à appeler ça le libre-arbitre.
Je sais pas vous, mais moi cette position-là, j'ai un peu
l'impression que c'est tricher, c'est-à-dire que
on redéfinit ce qu'on appelle le libre-arbitre juste
pour sauver l'idée qu'on a un libre-arbitre.
En même temps, il faut un peu comprendre
les gens qui pensent ça, parce que si demain,
tout le monde était convaincu que le
libre-arbitre n'existe pas,
il pourrait y avoir des conséquences sociétales
qui seraient assez catastrophiques.
aujourd'hui tout notre système de justice est
basé sur l'idée de responsabilité individuelle,
c'est-à-dire que si je commets un crime, on va pouvoir
me juger et éventuellement me condamner
parce que je suis responsable de ce que j'ai fait.
C'est-à-dire que j'avais la possibilité de ne pas le faire,
j'aurais pu faire autrement.
Sauf que si demain on dit le
libre-arbitre, ça n'existe pas,
comment vous voulez me dire que
j'avais la possibilité de faire autrement?
Sans compter que si demain, tout le monde devient
convaincu que le libre-arbitre n'existe pas,
il y a un petit risque que les gens
se mettent à faire n'importe quoi.
Par exemple, il y a quelques années, une étude a montré
que les gens qui ne croyaient pas au libre-arbitre,
étaient plus enclins à tricher que les autres
Vous voyez qu'en définitive, l'important ce n'est pas
tellement de savoir si le libre-arbitre existe ou pas,
c'est surtout qu'il faut que tout le
monde soit convaincu qu'il existe.
Alors quand même, la prochaine fois que
vous êtes pris en excès de vitesse
je vous déconseille d'essayer de dire
au flic que non, vous n'y êtes pour rien,
c'est juste une série de réactions chimiques dans
votre cerveau qui vous ont fait appuyer sur la pédale.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo, si elle vous a plu, vous
pouvez exercer votre libre-arbitre et la partager.
Vous pouvez aussi vous abonner à la chaîne
et me retrouver sur Facebook et sur Twitter.
Vous pouvez aussi me lire sur mon blog
qui s'appelle "Science Étonnante". A bientôt!
Sous-titres: Warteks